あみんな付きあき俺はんですけどティアンに行くといろんなメニューがあると思うん
ですけどもみなさんは何を高めます僕最近はもうマグロ通し方までないんですけども
すき家には裏メニューというものがございますネットで調べばちょちょいのちょい
ずにもネットでねすき家裏目に打って調べたらすき家の裏メニュー. com みたい
なサイトが出てくるんですよねこれを見るとさまざまな裏メニューがあるの
タイでございますおっと勘違いしないでくれオール技がネットの情報
見ただけすくい上げる新ネズミがないからわからないんですけどもそれは今回
確かめようという動画でございます凄いよ流れ金の牛丼とか有名なんですけども
トッピング全部乗せとパパっと見ねーこれはないんじゃねーかみたいな恨みでもあるん
ですよ今からコロネット村に上がってるすき家の裏メニューが本当
にできるかどうかっていうのを
雨てアガラが折れたこの僕が責任を持って調査していこうと思いますありそうのエロ
メンにも普通にあるんで
明らかにこれはないだろみたいな裏メニューがあればちょっと食べてみたいと思います
姉御
ああああああ
20 ana
ん
青も疲れないですけどもうダメに三茶ねこたまてみたくて
紅生姜ドってありますかないですよないこれ以外は基本的にない
そうですなるほど分かりました裏目に見たいねってじゃあここで食べて行くしかないよ
ねそうでさあちょっとさあし
ua いたリバティです気合い入ってきました結果から言いましょうつまり裏メニュー
というものはほぼない
なかったなが夜中に行って店員さんもすごい暇そうだったんでちょっと聞いてみたん
ですけど大塚会で本当には顔も使えるのメニューに書いてある奴しかためらしくて本当
にある裏目にっていうのはまああの金が牛丼とかあとキングカレー
あとキング2ノット
キング c ぞ三島裏メニューとして存在するらしいんですけれどもそれ以外の中
ネットに載っているラメにっていうのは基本的にないらしいです
が起こっている親怒ってるわけじゃないぞってわけじゃないんですけどもそっかと思っ
てやっぱこ裏メニューと聞くと高テンション上がっ積んで目がもっとやべぇのとかあっ
たら嬉しかったなと思ったんですけどもう何でもそれ以外にもなんかネットでいろんな
情報があったので実際にすき家切ってちょっとてきそうだったもっと寄ってくるみたい
な
こういうたの見方もあるんだぜみたいなのちょっとなんかをやってみたので参考にして
ください
はいどうぞまず1つめ33種のチーズ牛丼を食べますかうめーよ
他の3チーム牛の甘いんですけどもあるの弱点としては高ご飯
牛肉チークってなっちゃってなんかうまくご飯にチーズがかからないということを負っ
た人いると思いますよもうこんな裏技があったんで本当に勝負ネイルアートなんです
けどもうあの実はチーズ牛丼太郎の時にチーズを下にしてくださいって言ったら
ごはんチーズ牛肉になりますパッと見た他の牛刀に見えるんですけどもこれ牛肉の下に
チーズがのってます砂
ご飯に溶けたチーズが見事に絡まりあって生まれてリゾットみたいにかっていうという
あの
こっちの方が100倍良い姿勢一にご飯の方がでリゾットみたいなとうれしかったと
思いますチーズけど多分1コンだからこれにした方がいいんじゃないかなってぐらい
まとまりがあった気がしましたそして次
これ何だと思いますかそうだ曇りだけもにってって呼吸とターンの時に知るちょっと
あると思うんですけどもおもしぇるをお店の限界レベルまで上げたらな
汁物になっちゃったそして次はこちら牛丼なんですけどほとんどまさに年帰宅といっ
たらこうだけました
もうほぼ肉がないっていう
最高にヘルシーだねでのこの2つに関しては行ってくれる店舗とやらない店舗がある
らしいので僕これやってくれなかったので二展望面他の店まで行って行ってもらいまし
た
あーそして裏メニューっていうのはないんですけども
要するに好き家にあるもので組み合わせて売っていない右を作るの恨み言っていう言い
方もするみたいねあのすごいこりゃいいや
てみたかったなという裏メニューがあったんで行ってみましたこちらだ
10プリン盗んでスプリームズボンデビュー取りにプリンをのせるとできるらしい
ネットだと美味しいみたいなことが書かれていたので実際に行ってみました
あの
美味しくはなかった該当曜日で如何だったでしょうがまあ裏メニューというのは
ちょっとそんなにするはするんですけども
ネットに言われていることたくさん大課長が丼とかもなかったしてまーだ実際に好きな
トッピングとかねだから頼み方しないでといきますっていうのがたくさんあったよって
いうお話でした
マーモットなぁもっと大学校やべーラビにとあったらすごい演奏だったんですけども
まぁけどなんかちょっと
スッキリ出しましたねずラーメン食いてぇ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ